hopefully tomorrow in the assumptions
panel and today wasn't will tell us
about cryptographic artists of corrected
sampling
okay so um what I'm going to tell you is
a very small piece about this very small
piece of a much larger project that's
joint work with Mark Bond Marco
gabordi Max Hopkins rexley
um
Shiva Kumar
Maybe
can you hear me okay and um
and um I want to thank uh Sachi for all
I'm borrowing all of his good slides and
inserted my own bad slides so the good
ones are by Suchi
okay and the the the bigger topic is
replicability in learning
so um what is what is replicability
um well you kind of hear in the
newspaper about a replicability crisis
in science right the uh the idea is we
want to like if we do redo it experiment
we want to get the same results or
similar results so you can think of like
stability as if you redo an experiment
you want to get similar results
um
in replicability means uh if you redo
the experiment you get the same result
and that seems
and and we're talking about redoing the
experiment with new data starting from
scratch using the same methodology using
the same algorithms but collecting new
data so how could you possibly get the
same result
so uh so
replicability seems like a very strong
notion of stability
okay
um
uh so in terms of an algorithm we're
going to say that an algorithm a that
uses Randomness r
is row replicable
if for any Distribution on the inputs if
you pick M samples from twice from the
same distribution and run the algorithm
twice using the same Randomness with
high probability one minus rho you get
exactly the same answer
and this was a a notion that was kind of
inspired by work on two different a
pseudo deterministic algorithms but it
kind of flips it to the deterministic
algorithms you want the algorithms
result to depend on the input but not
the randomness here we want the
algorithm's result to depend on the
randomness but not the input
you don't do it is because you can't get
as far as I understand
well say here you know say you wanna
have a scientific study right
uh you want your results
to apply equally well to someone else
you know your results on your subject
say if then you're going to extrapolate
to the real world and you want to say
what happens in the real world is
exactly the same as what what it would
happen or why would we please
yeah I'll use it on your samples but but
also conceptually what this says is that
um so it's also a better is so it
combines like generalization with
privacy because if the result only
depends on the Readiness not on the
particular data then I'm not linking any
information about which data I used
so keeping the entire data specifics of
the data Secret
except with this probability row
that's an immediately implied that the
results
it allows you to further work to make
your trip for instance you need to show
that the randomness is random and stuff
like that well okay so I am assuming
that we can like pick the Randomness at
random and we are like looking at
different things like what if someone is
trying to like P hack and uh pick the
randomness that's going to help them
right
um but that's not I'm not going to talk
about that today
um so any more questions about the the
definition because
and this was uh it was independent work
by uh gazi Kumar and um
uh is that why are you requiring sorry
but uh
distributions it could be interesting
yeah
um okay so the strongest Nokia news with
respect to any distribution but the main
thing uh uh you know so we can relax the
notion later but the main uh I think you
really want to like say Okay correctness
is
uh what's going to happen if I have a
kind of distribution of the type that
I'm guessing
but I don't want
um the results to be invalid so that's
kind of like an assumption and I want my
algorithm to validate that assumption
so if I run it on a different type of
distribution
and the algorithm says
your assumptions are invalid on one run
they shouldn't say your assumptions are
valid on another
so uh so like you can like make often
we're like talking about correctness is
going to be with respect to
distributions that are kind of
parameterized in the right way when
gaussians or something but we want
replicability actually to hold for even
if that assumption isn't is incorrect
last question yes should I be thinking
that R is the number of samples
um usually the length of R is going to
be like poly logarithmic in the number
of samples but we don't cry We're Not
Gonna
in this talk we're not going to try to
bound that uh hopefully like future
talks like this stuff in more like uh as
I said this this paper by Grossman and
Lou looked at this in the in the context
of small space algorithms and there they
were particularly concerned with
limiting the the number dividing up the
randomness into the part that you needed
for referability and maybe the rest
of the Affairs so that that is of
interest but I'm kind of under
aggression for weather for my main topic
today
okay
because I might get to something
okay so uh and it's related to Notions
of global stability
so uh is can we come up with a reputable
algorithm or is this like a ridiculously
strong definition
yeah well so you could drop at zero all
the time so we don't want to do that
right because we want to make we want a
reputable algorithm that's actually
useful for something so zero all the
time is a rapid cool algorithm meets the
definition
let's see if there's something else
okay
all right
yeah so um so here here's like our our
first replica algorithm that we came up
with is to estimate the bias of a coin
okay so uh so the samples are going to
be like zero one valued samples
okay and we want to give an estimate of
the probability that the the samples are
one
okay
thing you try if you didn't care about
rapability it's just complete the
empirical averages you flip the coin a
large number of times and you uh
estimate the fraction that our heads and
that's the fraction you believe are
going to be hit and this is a good
algorithm in terms of the probability of
success of getting a good estimate is
pretty high it's stable in that if you
do it again you'll get a civil result
but it's not replicable in our terms
because you won't get identical results
you'll get like plus or minus
a little bit
so uh so but maybe like if we round
instead of like giving the exact value
we round
um that works good well for
replicability most of the time
um but
um if you're you know at the border
between buckets it's neither replicable
nor stable because sometimes you'll
round up sometimes you'll round down
if you do random shifting then you get a
replical algorithm great
so that's what we do
okay
um
and you pay a little bit in in terms of
the sample complexity
okay great you're ahead of me so I'm
going to skip ahead pass okay so and we
showed that like using similar ideas you
can get a lot of replica algorithms for
a lot of things in our previous paper
so um
now
uh so what I'm
did in the more recent work with the
whole the whole list of authors is we
used a generalized randomized routing
you'll see kind of this shift and round
is like a what works for one-dimensional
problems but there's a general method
for uh for kind of rounding
distributions called correlated sampling
and we show that this is a generic way
of converting stability to replicability
yeah
what you care about business
then
it's always one of those scenarios that
he could might as well just give an age
of outputs
so so if you look at what we're doing
we're basically giving a range of
outputs right but you still we still
want that range to be replica
so we want to give the same same range
on different lines of the algorithm just
based on the remnants not
um not either you can like give
consistent intervals but we want to
actually give the same interval
my receipt with privacy yeah
right so one reason to want
replicability
is it very modular okay so say you want
to compose algorithms
if you want to like reason about all
this this these kind of Windows are
going to be consistent and then we're
going to do this 100 times and it's
still going to be relatively consistent
it's hard to think about
if you think about replicability oh we
run the algorithm twice we get the same
answer we go to the next stage it's
exactly the same
and keep on going rather hold the next
stage and so on then the composition is
a lot simpler to think about so that's
another reason to want exact
applications
so they're they're different Notions of
stability and what we do is basically
show for a bunch of different Notions of
stability that
they're all uh equivalent
so what we get is like okay and there's
lots of other Notions of stability so we
give like one notion is perfectly
generalizing
uh another is differentially private or
approximately differentially private in
another applicability whether like five
or six others that you can put in this
picture and we can like use this these
Notions to show that as far as sample
complexity of algorithms all of these
Notions are equivalent so you're
actually proposing this is a new notion
of stability there's a new notion of
stability is kind of a strong notion but
it's equivalent to the rest
and
um by going around the circle we
actually can like improve the parameters
in a lot of the for a lot of the
different Notions so for example
um we get uh like a a way of improving
the the you know taking an Epsilon Delta
approximate different if you're private
and reducing the delta
without like increasing the Epsilon very
much and without increasing the sample
complexity much
yeah
think about the perfect generalization
so what does that mean can you just like
so uh okay so
so
perfect generalization is
uh is very similar in many ways to our
notion of replicability it means that if
we run the algorithm twice and here
there isn't like a Randomness and that's
necessary it could be randomized but
it's not important well or you you do
like have different Randomness sorry and
you look at the distribution and outputs
the Distribution on outputs globally
uh is very close
is very close to the distribution uh
if you run in a second time with new
data so that's very similar to what
we're doing in a lot of ways because we
we want the same result our results to
kind of depend on the data on on the
distribution but on the particular data
this is also saying that but we can't
but there's some difficulty in like
lining up converting this perfectly
General even this perfectly generalizing
algorithm to having exactly being
exactly equals uh with different
different Randomness so and that's the
main thing I wanted to talk about now
and I'm like behind schedule so I'm just
going to skip to that part if that's
okay because that's the part that um
that actually is non-computational we
show that it's information theoretically
possible to convert but um but it's
actually not always a computationally
possible
and let me and that kind of like going
to be tied into the to the um
uh to the theme of this Workshop okay so
what we show is like assuming uh that
Raven public key encryption is secure
then we actually can't
do this Arrow where we're converting uh
perfectly candles that generalizing
algorithms to replicable algorithms
um we also showed but but on the other
hand uh if there are no one-way
functions and on average you can do the
conversion
uh and if there are no uh non-uniform or
I think what was called it earlier
auxiliary input one-way functions then
the equivalence holds in the worst case
so um so you need some kind of
cryptographic assumption but we're not
quite
clear on exactly what the minimal
cryptographic assumption needed for the
to separate these Notions computational
yeah
well yeah okay so um that's the property
that we're using uh
[Music]
okay so um
Okay so
um
so
what's the main tool that we use to
convert a perfectly generalizing
algorithm to a replica algorithm
well
uh so what we have
is in a perfectly generalized
generalizing algorithm we know that the
Distribution on possible outputs is
close
and we want to convert that to like a
one-to-one correspondence between the
different outputs there's a a really
good notion that's been in the
literature for a while called correlated
sampling that does exactly that
and he's saying like oh you state what
you want and then you say what does
correlated sampling do and correlated
sampling does exactly what we want in
this step see so let me say what is
correlated sampling
correlated sampling takes an input
distribution p
and it
is a method for sampling from p
using using Randomness r
so that if you use the same method with
a distribution q
and Q is close to p
then with high probability you get the
same answer and close means close in
total variation distance
okay
so um so the chance of you're not
getting the same answer is exactly
proportional to the statistical distance
between these distributions
um
oh and it's the same distribution is
this so so you know a significant thing
is that
you don't have to know what Q is when
you're doing the correlated sampling
from P
so the the as you vary over R you'll get
samples from p over here you'll get
samples from Q over here they may not be
the same distribution but you'll get the
same answer except to the extent of the
distribution step
this is been known like information
theoretically or if you're given
explicitly what the distributions are on
a finite uh on a finite domain
foreign
it's not even a new idea to apply it in
this kind of setting okay but uh but it
works perfectly for what we want
um so here we're what are the
distributions that we're running
correlated sampling on it's like take
your your data it's not the distribution
of your data
is the distribution for a fixed set of
data as you vary over the randomness in
your algorithm and produce a result
whatever that result is so if the
Distribution on results outputs of your
algorithm as you vary over all the
randomness in your output
and we're going to want to sample from
the same distribution but with this
correlated sampling uh method method
okay
now uh so because we're just our
distributions are just given to us by
the algorithm we don't have an explicit
description of the of the uh
of the distribution so we need to do
this correlated sampling in a white box
wedge where we're given not the
distribution explicitly but a sampling
procedure for that distribution
uh and this can be like hard
to do uh so here's like an example where
we're like using ribbon encryption say
that
um we're going to be generating samples
we're given input X and the sampler is
going to pick X and multiply by r
squared
okay so um if x and x Prime are both
quadratic residues this is not just
close it's the same distribution random
quadratic residues if they're not if one
of them is not a quadratic residue then
they're just totally disjoint
distributions
related sampling for these two
distributions for this kind of
distribution then
um we would learn just by telling
whether x equals we get the same result
we would learn whether uh you know we
could run it with a a known quadratic
residue and we could tell whether X is a
quadratic residue or not
so this is one example where it's hard
to do correlated sampling more generally
uh if you think about what we're doing
if we're showing that anything is the
the complete problem for statistical
zero knowledge is given two
distributions to estimate how close they
are
and that's exactly what we're doing if
we could do correlated sampling we can
as a side effect estimate how close
distributions are by just seeing how
often the samples are equal
uh so if you have a correlated sampling
generic correlated white box correlated
sampling algorithm then statistical zero
knowledge is
um
okay
and in fact now this doesn't show that
the the Privacy is hard to convert to
replicability but you can like modify
this construction to show that
on the other hand uh what we show is
that if there are no auxiliary one-way
functions uh no auxiliary input one-way
functions uh then uh there's a white box
correlated sampling algorithm
uh and if there are no one-way functions
and they're on any pretty good
distribution there's an average case
white box standpoint can you go back to
the previous one okay to the
impossibility yeah
so
so you're saying that there's no way to
convert an algorithm but you don't know
but you can say but you don't have an
example of
um well we do uh where where it is
possible but not
so you have to like go to a stronger
cryptographic assumption using like a
more thick encryption and there are
problems that the officials okay
so here here sort of like if you knew
how to factor then you'd have both types
of algorithms so uh
it's not clear
that they're either even
it just it just says that uh there's no
uniform construction of one type of
algorithm from the other
uh
okay but on the other hand if there are
no one-way functions then you get this
kind of white box correlated sampling
algorithm uh which I think uh I don't
have much time to talk about how you do
that
so but it's kind of like music
okay
so so here's here's like a warm-up case
say that we knew some value p and knew
that for our distributions that that we
carried about everything was in a factor
of two a probability p
okay so uh the actual probability is
under the distribution so we know that
for particular the distributions have a
Theta one and P elements so what we're
going to do is compose our sampling
algorithm with a random hash function
in maths strings to about Theta 1 over P
elements output outputs of our of our
sampling procedure
and then uh we want to find like random
pre-images of the composition of the
sampling procedure in the hash function
and pick Y at random to kind of commit
to which element we're using now
um and we invert but then not that we
don't use the r we're interested in the
x that you get by sampling using r
okay and we keep on going until we find
one and if um
then
uh assuming we can compute this
probability okay which we can if there
are no one-way functions then uh on
average then we can like use rejection
sampling to to normalize and get the
correct distribution
you can see that because we're using if
we use the same hash function
and the two distributions are close then
with high probability we'll commit to
the same X
so um okay so if we want to like
generalize this let's break up our
distribution into levels based on uh an
estimate of PT event so like break it up
into levels that are all within a factor
of two of each other and then use
correlated sampling on the levels rather
than the actual uh output entire output
to pick a level and then conditionally
use the method I just gave to pick
within that level
but there are a couple of problems with
this so so first is uh if we uh break it
up into levels even if distributions are
close they might move an X from one
level to another
just by like moving it up or down a
notch in in probability
and since we only give an estimate for
the probabilities maybe X is on the
border of uh uh uh
that's what I was going to point to hip
talk yeah so you talk you know what to
do next right one
um we we do the same trick and we pick
this Factor beta and shift all the
levels by a random Factor beta
and uh so um
so that's the main idea the um
uh now we've got like a number we've got
some uh hardness results based on
specific crypto cryptographic
assumptions we'd like them more generic
way yeah you can talk about random
self-reducible
um but it's not a very nice assumption
there's you know when you look at what
you have the conditions that have to
satisfy it almost like uniquely defines
ray-band encryption okay so um so we'd
like to also like uh
really understand the assumptions we
need for correlated sampling and uh and
look at in general what other uh
cryptographic assumptions have to do
about hardness and easiness for
separating different models of learning
um
yes
the jokes by organizers it was outroaded
okay
so okay okay
so okay so this is a joint work